wall he guess who I just saw inside in
this McDonald's not only is he inside
he's actually eating a
cheeseburger brothers and sisters just
imagine for a second that you give £10
in donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing D that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this w this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
truear I myself will be donating for
that inshah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana bless and
preserve you guys guys I'm in McDonald's
and slow and W he guess who I just saw
inside I saw Ali dawa inside he's in
this McDonald's not only is he inside
he's actually eating a cheeseburger and
I'm going to show you now if you don't
believe
me let me show you guys
in M Ali boy boy boy call McDonald's
yeah and you're basically
munching you're munching in uh in
McDonald's yeah I'm having my burger bu
bro yeah if you guys don't believe me I
listen listen I see what's happening
here bro bro you you got a million
subscribers yeah subscribe to me and
you're eating McDonald's yourself no you
need to subscribe to my Channel first
yeah but let me tell you something
listen listen sit on a level yeah this
is messed up bro listen listen it's not
messed up it tastes actually very nice
BR is that is that even Hal Long oh my
gosh oh my gosh this is mag look at
this come sit next to me man brothers
and sisters you want to come McDonald's
the only thing I'm going to use this bag
is to vom inside is it nice brother and
sister of course it's nice have you
tried fat BNS before you know what I
thought about you know what I said I
said I'm going to probably come to this
across Quran guy here's yours yeah keep
it don't touch it don't get don't touch
it yet don't get too excited we're
talking about boycott you want to eat
food brothers and sisters McDonald's
when the first attacks happened in
Palestine McDonald's was the ones who
were supplying the IDF with free meals
free meals yes so brothers and sisters
we are going to inshallah have Burgers
but we're not going to have burgers from
McDonald's we're going to have Burgers
from fat buns why because their buns are
fat what does that mean they're very
tasty try it have you tried it I've
tried it I think yeah I I uh tried it
the other day it was actually delicious
but I did not know that you'd be hiding
inside the McDonald's B no no you have
to cuz I'm going to use this to be do
that vomit inside it yes in a minute
we're going to get kicked out of
McDonald's brother sisters but it's time
we support our Muslim owned places
brother and sisters fat buns as you can
see brother and sister behind me and
this is where the real buns are
alhamdulillah not those fith buns fat
buns has opened up in SL it's also
opened up in Bas top and it's up north
as well my first time tried it in
Birmingham and I was making D they come
around London but they came to SL that's
close enough this burger I'm not a
burger guy brother and sisters you need
to try the fat cheese and what's the
other one and the all the the beef is
fresh they actually grind it in the
store not like mcdonaldz mdon not Patty
not like a McDon burger that it lasts
for 3 years without decaying or your
chips last for like 10 years so your
grandkids can eat them yeah um sisters
boycott McDonald heavily inshallah we
don't need it the food is dead it's
jiting anyway try fat BNS from now on
brothers and sisters it's in baseb and
not for that matter any Muslim compan in
the UK I I would I would I would have to
agree that cuz I'm not a burger guy and
I tried it and it is one of the best
burgers I've had fres and for that
matter any Muslim companies that sell
this problem sisters it is much better
than you supporting companies like
McDonald's who directly indirectly
support the idea of and Israel and if
you give something up for the sake of
Allah Allah will give you something
better trust me I'm living that right
now I'm living right now brother and
sisters carry on the boycott until we
come with the next Bas of
boycot that was not yours actually I was
just pretending on
camera actually cut the camera cut the
camera